[Musique]
bonjour bruno retailleau bonjour elle
est bête martichoux merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin je disais
président du groupe plr au sénat est
également président du mouvement forces
républicaines vous avez en cela succéder
à françois fillon on aura peut-être
l'occasion d'en parler mais d'abord si
vous me permettez cette accusation de
régimes autoritaires qui aurait été
instauré par emmanuel macron en france
accusation martelé depuis des semaines
par jean luc mélenchon plus récemment
par ségolène royal et c'est nouveau par
marine le pen
hier soir sur lci et côté oui c'est un
régime qui aujourd'hui utilisent des
moyens qui sont autoritaires et c'est
même je vais vous dire un gouvernement
je crois qui peut accumuler le plus
grand nombre de reculs en matière de
libertés individuelles et en matière de
grandes libertés publiques
à la question est-ce un régime
autoritaire elle répondait oui au micro
de david pujadas hier soir bruno
retailleau est-ce que vous reprendriez à
votre compte cet argument non je ne le
reprendrait pas parce que je le trouve
excessif et pourtant je ne suis pas
quelqu'un qui ménage parfois mes
critiques vis-à-vis des emails macron je
pense que la nature notamment de la
gouvernance mails macron c'est une
nature profondément égocentrique la
verticalité macro nien c'est quoi c'est
un homme seul finalement et c'est
peut-être ce qui donne cette apparence
d'autoritarisme
il ya une tan dung une autorité
verticale qu'on peut confondre
effectivement avec le totémisme et
souvenez-vous en marche c'est em ce sont
finalement les initiales des mails
macron emmanuel macron est à lui-même
son propre projet politique et je trouve
que concernant les libertés
individuelles
il y a eu des lois préoccupante je me
suis opposé par exemple à la loi faits
qui vit je me suis opposé aussi le sénat
ait compris d'ailleurs pratiquement sur
tous les groupes sur tous les bancs à la
fameuse loi avia qui voulait privatiser
la censure
on voulait on voulait donner aux
multinationales
voire de censurer alors qu'on veut
réguler les multinationales les gars
femmes les google et caetera et on leur
donnait le pouvoir de régulation suprême
sur notre bien le plus précieux qui la
liberté d'expression' en fait par
courrier recul ça n'en fait pas pour
autant un régime
autre habitué vous est ce que ça vous
inquiète
est ce que vous voyez là une forme aussi
de relativisme dans le débat public
cette ses accusations ses invectives et
même ces violences physiques aussi qu'a
dénoncé hier edouard philippe assez
solennellement assez fermement hier
l'assemblée à l'occasion des questions
au gouvernement
voilà ce climat qui fait que
effectivement vous dites il ya des
formules qui sont excessives des
accusations excessive et des menaces
physiques aussi qu'ils sont banalisés
anne hommel et les menaces physiques on
doit les condamnés ferme
est ce que vous êtes suffisamment vous
offre cette ville et par leurs affaires
en marche assure bien sûr on vous entend
ça mais seulement y compris par tweet je
l' ai toujours fait ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que le climat est malsain
le climat est malsain c'est un climat
d'insécurité et je pense qu'ils mêlent
macron en est pour partie responsables à
ses curés
je m'explique insécurité je vais
m'expliquer il est responsable de ce
climat dans la mesure où il divise
on parlera tout à l'heure de l'algérie
mais je trouve que depuis deux ans et
demi et melle macro et besoin de boucs
émissaires
il a eu des phrases parfois malheureuses
les gens qui ne sont rien ceux qui
réussissent et a eu besoin de boucs
émissaires c'était des retraités c'était
les élus et cetera et ça je pense que
les français leur sang il est anxiogène
parce que le en même temps est anxiogène
et cela place les français dans un
climat d'insécurité à sécurité physique
regarder les derniers chiffres de la
délinquance
les homicides +8 5% les viols +10 9%
les escroqueries etc insécurité culturel
on y reviendra aussi y'a pas une vraie
lutte contre l'islamisme en france je
pense qu'on est en train de perdre la
bataille et insécurité économique à
l'origine du chemin les chiffres du
chômage qui ont été publiés vendredi
dernier sont bons il faut s'en réjouir
je pense qu'il faut s'en réjouir mais
derrière cette joie qu'on peut avoir à
cette baisse qui malheureusement est
trop faible
faut comparer la france aux autres
grandes économies occidentales et
surtout européenne
et quand on se compare on se désole
puisque l'allemagne c'est un peu plus de
3%
en clair le taux de chômage de masse en
france et plus du double de ce qu'il est
ailleurs dans les grands dangers connus
réjouir mais immédiatement dans la
foulée le relativiser bien sûr on l'aura
nativistes de même que ce que je
relativise c'est que si la croissance
aujourd'hui plus porteurs en emploi
c'est parce que on a moins de
productivité parce qu'il ya une
désindustrialisation et il ya des
emplois dans les services qui sont moins
bien payés qui sont moins productifs
en clair on a c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que il ya un mal être des classes
moyennes parce qu on a remplacé des
salaires dans l'industrie à 40000 euros
à 45000 euros par des salaires notamment
services à la personne à 20 25 mille
euros et ça ça crée des frustrations
vous parlez de la pas de là une forme de
précarité précarisés je parle de cette
polarisation en france beaucoup plus
qu'ailleurs du marché du travail où vous
avez un marché pour les très qualifiés
avec qui gagnent de chair bien sûr et
qui est bien leur vie et un marché pour
les moins qu'elle nous l'enjeu la
formation professionnelle de
l'apprentissage aussi vous avez dit
c'est un climat malsain et vous avez
immédiatement visé cible emmanuel macron
il est le seul comptable deux de ceux-ci
de ce climat
vous pensez que c'est le seul
responsable il ya dans ce convoi dans la
radicalité des oppositions c'est c'est
lui j'essaie j'essaie de ne pas de
simpliste j'observe aussi compris
puisque j'étais en train de faire une
comparaison sur le chômage
je sais que dans les grandes démocraties
occidentales elles sont toutes taraudé
par des questions existentielles et et
c'est vrai parfois de la violence
simplement il est le chef de l'état et
regardez la réforme des retraites qui
est l'exemple de ce qu'on ne devrait
jamais faire en tant que réforme
pourquoi et pourquoi est ce que la
réforme des retraites est en train
d'hystériser les français parce que
quand on fait une réforme il faut que ce
que l'on dit avant pendant une campagne
présidentielle soit ensuite aligné par
les faits et malheureusement ça n'est
pas le cas quelques exemples mails
macron avait dit écoutez je ne toucherai
pas ou 62 ans
et il propose l'âge pivot il ya une
contradiction il avait dit je
ne toucherait pas au pouvoir et achats
je touche auriez vous en réjouir
bien sûr bien sûr simplement ce que
j'avais fait d'ailleurs un peu construit
nous avons nous dit il faut qu'on
travaille plus longtemps et quand
finalement le projet de loi
effectivement exercer un travail plus
longtemps vous dit des témoins
ce que je dis c'est que il ne doit pas y
avoir une contradiction dans entre
l'avant et l'après
nous avons toujours été clairs et nous
avons fait cette réforme va évoluer
messi mais on a toujours été clair il
faut travailler plus simplement lui adil
inverse d'hommes qui l'a dit un verre
sur les complémentaires avec le débat
avec madame le pen d'être visionné les
on va être très précis il à dire je ne
toucherai pas l'âge légal ça voulait pas
dire que par le biais par exemple la
durée des cotisations a sidéré la pad il
faudra jamais travailler plus longtemps
c'était très clair il allait 62 ans il a
dit vous
il a 90 et je les relis d'ailleurs dans
un débat interrogé sur ce sujet là les
choses étaient très très claire elle
était très claire aussi
il avait dit je ne toucherai pas au
pouvoir d'achat la première chose qu'il
a fait il a désindexé des retraites
il avait dit dans le débat avec madame
le pen vous pourrez re visionner on ne
touchera pas en préservant les
complémentaires et là il touche aux
complémentaires donc les français ne
peuvent pas comprendre c'est lorsque il
ya un langage de l'avant et un langage
de la prayssac hystérise didot est ce
qu'un passage en force à l'assemblée
vraiment bien sûr vous il propose six
essieux un passage en force mais ils
respectent ces passants c'est un peu à
proprement parler il respecte un
calendrier parlementaire
non attendez vous avez une réforme et
vous savez qu'au sénat jette en
conférence des présidents qui avait
réuni gérard larcher hier pratiquement
les groupes ont voté à la quasi
unanimité
il ya deux groupes mais ils se sont
abstenus les indépendants et puis le
groupe en marche pour que on demande aux
prisons de république au gouvernement
d'avoir de lecture dans chaque assemblée
pourquoi le conseil d'état je n'ai
jamais vu d'avis aussi rude du conseil
d'état sur la réforme des retraites nous
y voilà l'étude d'impact elle est
lacunaire elle est insuffisante ya une
insécurité juridique
on y voit pas c'est inintelligible c'est
illisible et donc pour que l'on puisse
améliorer on bouge un système qui est là
depuis 45 qui concerne chaque français
il faut quand même que le parlement et
notamment les députés vous imaginez les
députés ils vont travailler dans
quelques jours sur un texte
dont ils ne savent pas comment il va
être financé puisque la conférence de
financement va se dérouler en parallèle
pourquoi est-ce qu'en france c'est aussi
urgent on modifie jamais dans le pathos
matériaux vous n'avez jamais jamais à
droite recouru à une procédure si j'ai
l'airé donc on rappelle c'est une seule
lecture / 2 / pour une réforme des
retraites jamais mais la seule
différence les artichauts c'est que les
réformes que nous avons fait et
heureusement nous les avons faites
je vous rappelle que si nous n'avions
pas fait le régime actuel se trouvera en
déficit car la procédure et 40 milliards
qui manquerait la procédure la plupart
du temps d'ailleurs ce n'est pas en
accéléré sauf que ces têtes des réformes
paramétriques on ne changeait pas le
système on s'appuyait sur un système
existant et ont changé les paramètres
c'est-à-dire soit la durée de cotisation
plus souvent d'ailleurs le recul de
l'âge légal de départ
ça n'a rien à voir votre contestation
senna bruno retailleau c'est un baroud
d'honneur
ce que ce que vous n'avez pas pu obtenir
vous n'avez pas beaucoup manifesté on
vous a pas beaucoup vu dans les défilés
mais ce que la rue n'a pas obtenu vous
espérez que le cal le parlement
l'obtiennent c'est à dire ces
gouvernements cale ce que je veux dire
c'est que je parlais d'historisation ce
que le gouvernement doit comprendre
c'est que c'est quand il n'ya pas de
débouchés politiques quand il ya une
question une interrogation sur la
qualité de travail du parlement
mais alors c'est la rue qui prend le
pouvoir si on veut en france si on veut
en france une démocratie apaisée
alors il nous faut des procédures alors
il nous faut débattre cv la démocratie
c'est le règlement pacifique des
différends pas dans la rue mais au
parlement de de violences en tous cas de
chaos dans la russie au parlement il ne
doit plus le temps par le site évidence
c'est écouter ses skis c'est une
emmanuel macron c'est une évidence que
lorsqu'on donne aux oppositions le temps
au parlement ou parle nous sommes dans
une démocratie parlementaire
oui ou non on peut pas amputer un débat
sur quelque chose qui est aussi
important on va remettre en cause notre
pacte social qu'est ce qui le narrateur
sens alors si jamais il ne touche pas au
calendrier parlementaire que ce qui
menace la faune et le et le secteur a
voté avant l'été et le gouvernement aura
gagné la partie
non il n'aurait pas grippe l'important
ce n'est pas que le gouvernement gagne
la partie n'en fasse pas n'importe quand
sans qu'on fasse une bonne réforme
l'aref à écouter la réforme et les moves
elle est très mauvaise on a dit qu'elle
était universel c'est faux le conseil
d'état en atteste la seule universalité
je vais vous dire elle est universelle
dans son rejet qui est universel et
malheureusement elle ne l'est pas il a
une majorité emmanuel macron vous ne
pouvez pas dire le contraire tu fais la
démocratisation et bien sûr je pense
qu'il ya elle n'est pas mais je vous dis
que c'est leur majorité l'a bien sûr
mais dans une chambre le travail
parlementaire c'est un travail de
nuances
on essaie de poser un regard on essaie
de confronter ces arrivées jeudi croyez
moi il y en a tellement d'arguments que
on peut pas une démocratie ça peut pas
être seulement un mécanisme automatique
opposition et minorités y doit y avoir
un débat et on doit s'enrichir avec des
arguments échanges en émoi et moi il y
en a des arguments
on est en train je vais vous donner un
exemple on se plaint vous savez que je
pense que la crise et gilet jaune
c'est aussi le problème d'une société
bloquée l'ascenseur social qui est
bloquée aujourd'hui est bien la réforme
des retraites
ça va bloquer un peu plus l'ascenseur
social pourquoi donc
parce que jusqu'à présent vous avez vous
prenez pour eux dans le privé les 25
meilleures années donc quand vous avez
une carrière ascendante vous partez de
bas et puis vous vous élevez vous allez
prendre justement la meilleure partie de
la carrière
là ça sera l'ensemble de la carrière on
verra plus cette ascendance donc les
têtes d'oeuf
ceux qui sont sortis des grandes écoles
et ce point de départ aujourd'hui dans
la vie déterminent toute une carrière
professionnelle eux seront avantagés et
vous savez les carrières ces efforts les
carrières hachées par rapport à
aujourd'hui par exemple elle sera
perdante qui sont à temps partiel et
dont le peu de travail n'est pas pris en
compte parce que le calcul ne le permet
pas chaque heure travaillée contrat donc
ça c'est un avantage
eh bien je vais vous dire il est par
ailleurs juste donc vous parler d'un ex
à eau non non on comparait
d'universalité
c'est la première réforme qui crée un
régime spécial pour les riches première
réforme est une réforme qui crée pour
régis spécialement la mairie bien sûr
bien sûr
comment peut-on à partir de 120 mille
euros crée un régime de retraite ou à
partir du moment où vous toucherez à peu
près dix mille euros brut par mois vous
ne cotisez que 2,81 pour
plutôt que de cotiser 28,12 pour ce que
vous avez dit mais pour le cadre ne
cotisera pas pour lui même
ça va directement la solidarité non vous
n'avez que de 2,8 pour cent qui va
l'assurer il a été aujourd'hui vous avez
près de 10% qui va la solidarité c'est
300 mille euros manque à gagner pour les
2 67 milliards sur l'art jrc a
recommandé taille haute et je veux le
dire aux français ce n'est pas
raisonnable et ses skis series la seule
réforme des retraites qui crée un régime
spécial pour les riches c'est ce que
vous nous dites ce matin le dimanche de
la passion et je suis très chaud à le
démontrer point par point vous demande
si vous demandez à débattre avec le
premier ministre
je veux bien sûr ce point là et sur
d'autres points débattre avec lui mais
je veux que le premier ministre laisse
débattre le parlement le sénat
et puis l'assemblée nationale je veux
que le gouvernement parce que c'est une
réforme fondamentale pour chaque
français
pour aujourd'hui pour demain laisse du
temps au parlement pour parfaire cette
réforme qu'elle très imparfaite
brièvement c'est possible bruno
retailleau
pourquoi dites vous que emmanuel macron
met en péril notre unité tout simplement
les déclarations qu'il a faites
notamment sur l'algérie avec cette
comparaison hasardeuse
quelle est la phrase exacte la phrase
exacte c'est la guerre d'algérie a à peu
près le même statut que la shoah
pour jacques chirac non maintenant c'est
pas la phrase exacte et il a établi les
pins parallèle il est rétabli il
n'aurait pas à la comparer il est dans
leur statut alors on va avoir le statut
dans le statut de travail mémoriel je ne
sais pas la france mais ils n'ont voulu
emmanuel macron dans une interview à
radio j a effectué un rapprochement en
termes de travail mémoriel et et je sais
la valette a elle échoué louis et je
peux vous parler se polit la mauvaise
lecture de paris et on va y revenir
simplement vous ne pouvez pas quand vous
êtes président de république établir ce
type de parallèle y compris dans l'ordre
mémorial mémorielle mais y compris dans
le travail mémoriel je pense que c'est
une triple faute je vais vous dire
pourquoi
première faute vis-à-vis de nos soldats
français morts en algérie
première faute vis-à-vis d'eux
deuxième faute vis-à-vis notamment des
jeunes dans nos quartiers qui ont de la
peine à rentrer dans notre projet
national si vous dites que la france est
coupable de tout y compris de crimes
contre l'humanité l'art comment voulez
vous suffit ça suffit à une série
d'aventurés manuel macro razeq jaune en
sixième et de l'algérie je dis ça pour
le ce qu'ils nous entendent
il s'est interrogé effectivement haute
voix sur la façon dont lui président de
la république pourrait travailler en
termes de mémoire de travail de mémoire
sur la gueule d'argile et lui demande
mais jamais fait sur la la forêt la
france est un pays divisé
pitié pour la france la france est un
pays divisé il est en train de gratter
les plaie mémorielle donc troisième
faute à tous les 3e tour des 3e faute
n'aurait pas pu y toucher mais
certainement pas en établissement en
établissement des parallèles les
amalgames aussi hasardeux troisième
faute l'algérie l'algérie prospère le
fln a pillé par la corruption
son pays avec le prétexte de la
colonisation française
eh bien vous renforcer ce type de régime
en disant voilà les crimes contre
l'humanité c'est une triple fond on peut
pas travailler donc sur la guerre
d'algérie
je pense qu'il faut laisser la
repentance a su je demande à emmanuel
macron de laisser les historiens
travaillé sur l'histoire elle peut
travailler sur la mémoire
il a cité et avec martichoux il a cité
paul ricoeur je connais très bien cet
ouvrage que les spécialistes appellent m
machenaud mémoire histoire oublie paul
ricoeur parle justement des pathologies
de la mémoire
quelle est la pathologie française de la
mémoire c'est cette repentance
perpétuelle d'un côté on a centre on est
le pays où on a le plus en effet
coloriel on a compris et ensuite on a
une vision lacrymal et pénitentielle de
notre histoire et cette vision nous en
faire dans un pessimisme nous en nous
enferme dans la haine donné ma blague de
sannois culpabilisez pas les français et
sur ne divise les français ne divisait
ce que la france a besoin d'être divisée
avec ce la réforme et non en afrique si
meryl deux questions très brève pardon
jordan bardet la numéro 2 du
rassemblement national a dit récemment
il n'est pas de france emmanuel macron
je comprends pas cette phrase nec
on peut dire on peut dire qu'elle mêle
macron n'a pas fait un parcours par
exemple d'élus territoriales qui
l'aurait amené précisément à connaître
en profondeur les territoires de france
il un vrai problème d'ailleurs avec la
décentralisation
ça participe justement de son
parisianisme de la verticalité
bon il ya des territoires en france qui
sont très très divers mais cette phrase
là une fois de plus elle est
profondément excessive
françois fillon va venir s'expliquer la
télévision quelques semaines avant son
procès il n'aurait pas dû réserver ses
explications juge précisément pour nos
risques et pourquoi ce qui fait ça mais
parce que parce que le tribunal de
l'opinion le tribunal médiatique l'a
déjà quasiment jugé pendant l'élection
présidentielle
il va y avoir le temps de la justice le
temps de la justice se veut être un
temps de la sérénité
un temps de la nuance où on va apporter
des éléments à charge et à décharge très
bien mais je pense qu'il a à coeur de
s'expliquer directement devant les
français dans la mesure où un procès a
été instruit contre lui pendant la
campagne question d'honneur il sans
doute sans doute alors vous savez vous
savez que je n'aime pas parler pour lui
même donc je vais aller cyril s'exprimer
demain mais je pense en tout cas j'en
suis sûr qu'il a à coeur de dire sa
propre vérité aux français je le connais
c'est pas seulement un ami c'est
quelqu'un que je respecte beaucoup
il a une vision je sais qu'il aime la
france voilà maintenant une démarche
personnelle n'est pas une démarche
politique attend alors non non très
franchement certains envoient souvent
des cartes postales
croyez-moi françois fillon s'est
terminée la vie politique pour lui il ne
reviendra pas il n'entend pas par cette
émission adressé aux français une carte
postale
alors que vous vous préparer à toute
éventualité d'ici à 2029 merci bruno
retailleau d'avoir et les lakers chez
matin sur lci renault vient d'en
reparler journée